What's happening?
You're changing the future
and you change the past.
What did you want to know?
You're
You are
You're. Yeah.
I'm batman.
there might not be a future.
Barry, what are you doing?
Our kids are going to see this.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my new flash trailer video.
There was some new footage,
so we'll break it down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs.
Also, explain what's going on
with Reverse Flash in the DCU or DCU
now that James Gunn is rebooting
everything,
Everybody asking,
where is Reverse-Flash in all this?
Because he's a huge part
of the flashpoint story in the comics,
and they're using Flashpoint
for the story of the movie.
He does exist in the DCU,
like This New Universe is being created,
however you want to call it.
Technically,
according to James Gunn's comments,
he said that it's still going to be
the DCU until the end of the Flash movie,
when his changes will culminate in a
sort of soft reboot of the multiverse,
so to speak, and moves
directly into the Flash, A fantastic movie
that I really love
that resets the entire DC universe.
Then to move into Blue Beetle,
a fantastic film about a kid
who's a marvelous part of the DCU
and then into Aquaman 2,
which leads directly
into our next few projects.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
is a bunch of big stuff coming up.
But basically what's happening in
the movie is they're using a combination
of some of the flashpoint story
combined with the concept of hyper time,
like multiple timelines,
which is a little bit
more like the Loki series
in the Marvel Universe.
I'll explain that.
Within the DC universe,
we call it hyper time.
It's like a slightly different concept,
but it's the same basic idea
in a bit of a Savitar type of twist
from the Flash TV show,
or the way that the Flash TV show
used them because they changed
the character from the comics.
So it's a little bit closer to the version
that the TV show
used just in terms of what's going on
with the villains in the movie,
because there is a version
of an evil flash,
but he is not the reverse flash
that you know of.
I talked about this a couple of months ago
and people were confused like Evil Flash.
Are you talking about reverse flash?
No, Technically, the evil flash
in the movie that we're going to see
fighting the regular flash
that the Ezra miller main flash
is going to be another version
of Ezra miller from an alternate future
who just happened to turn evil
and is wearing a costume
that does look a little bit
like a version of a reverse flash costume
from the new 52,
like the Daniel Webster Flash.
You see the younger
Barry Allen wearing yellow.
That is a bit of a reference
to the fact that we will meet
an evil flash in the future.
But it's not that I'm saying
that he's replacing the reverse flash.
H is then trying to telegraph
that twist later in the film like,
Oh, there will be an evil flash
at some point in the future.
But I believe the is referring to him
as Dark Flash.
I'll talk about him in a second.
There isn't Eobard Thawne Reverse-Flash
inside this universe of the movies.
He's the person who killed Barry's mother.
That set off
everything that happens during the movie.
Like the whole plot of the movie
is because he wants to undo
his mother's death and go back
into the past, try and change that.
They've already done
all the backstory to set that up
and what's happening with it,
because his father was framed
for his mother's murder.
Because what happened
is, is that his mother was murdered.
His father found the body,
but they didn't find the killer.
So they assumed incorrectly,
that his father was the killer.
At the time, there wasn't enough evidence
to prove that he was not the killer.
And Barry was a young child
when it happened.
They did a version of this on the Flash
TV show in the very first episode
where the Reverse-Flash comes back
in time to kill Barry's mother, hoping
that he will break the Flash's sole
and he will not become The Flash
eventually.
What the Reverse Flash didn't know is it?
It was sort of a predestination paradox,
and the Flash would always wind up
becoming the flash.
Just hardship
just drove him to become a better person
over time than just who he is.
Is is that when the Reverse-Flash killed
his mother,
things happened a little bit differently.
Like Barry Allen
still wound up becoming the flash,
just not in the way that the Reverse-Flash
expected.
That's all going on inside the movies.
The reason why they didn't want to use
a reverse flash is like the main villain
of this very first flash movie is mostly
just because the Flash TV show
has been using the character
so much for the last several years,
and they're
trying to do like a completely new spin
on the whole concept of flash point.
So they're just taking
some of the story from the comics
because they already did a Justice
League flash point movie,
which is actually a great movie.
If you haven't seen it,
I would definitely recommend watching it.
It adapts the flashpoint story
from the comics much more faithfully
with all the Wonder Woman, the alchemy,
and like the larger
Universe Justice League crossover stuff,
the darker flash point Batman,
the evil version of Martha Wayne
that winds up
becoming the Joker in the Flashpoint
universe.
There's been a lot of cool concept
art of that.
And Jeffrey
Dean Morgan said that
he would definitely be willing
to play a version of Flashpoint Batman.
Like, I will come back and be that Batman.
It almost seemed like for a hot minute
they might wind up doing
something like that
because the Flash movie plot changed
so many times.
So many directors came and went,
but in the way that a lot of movie plots,
especially in the Marvel movies, to change
a lot of what happens in the original
comic book stories that they're based on.
What they're doing
with this version of Flashpoint
is they're saying that Reverse-Flash
killed Barry's mother, sort of sets off
everything that happens during the movie.
I think there are only light
Easter eggs to him in the film.
They'll probably do him in future films
as a much bigger character.
But in the present day,
after the events of the Justice League
movie like Time has Moved On
and Barry has continued to work
with the Ben Affleck version of Batman,
he's the one that gives him
the new flash ring from the comics
with his new flash suit In it.
They team up for a big save here
where things go crazy.
In enough time has gone by,
the Barry starts to get better
and better at using his powers.
He gets more powerful or he learns to use
his powers in a better way and eventually
becomes so powerful that he thinks
that he can actually change the past.
I can actually use this God to your power
to prevent my mother from dying
just because he's been stuck on it
his entire life since he was a little kid
in Remember, his father's been in prison
this whole time.
In present day.
He's been trying to get him out and
he thinks they're going back to save her.
Will also solve that problem, too.
Of course, in the trailers,
you see Ben Affleck's Batman telling him,
hell no, don't do that,
Basically giving him the sage advice.
This is only going to make things worse.
Some things you can't change.
The Marvel movies in Avengers, Endgame,
for instance, had a really creative
way of explaining this.
The whole idea is that the Marvel
writer said
that they talked to real world scientists
about how actual time
travel would work if people found a way
to travel back into the past.
And just based on real world physics
that we know right now, like the knowledge
that we have right now,
you actually can't change your own past.
You can only create new futures based
on things that you changed in the past.
And that's basically
what happens during the Flash movie here.
The Flash uses
the Speed Force to travel back in time,
but then the butterfly effect
starts to happen
and he starts to fracture what you think
of as hyper time in the DC Universe
in a bunch of timelines, start bleeding
into each other, changing the future.
So that's why there's no Justice
League on the earth that he's on,
even though he travel back
to his own past.
And he only went back about ten years
right before the events of the Man
of Steel movie.
Like when he's standing here
with a younger version of himself.
It's about 2013 before
Man of Steel picks up,
because when all these timelines
start bleeding together and it erases
his future Justice League timeline, like
there are no metahumans on earth anymore,
nobody is there on earth to protect them
from Zod and the Kryptonians.
That's why he takes his younger self,
goes to try and find Batman, thinking
that he'll find the Ben Affleck Batman,
but also learns that it's not him.
It's a totally different Batman.
It's Michael Keaton's Batman, who,
when the movie picks up, has been retired
for a while, like he's actually
put his suits into mothballs, so to speak.
And they go around trying to assemble
a new version of the Justice League
with what they can find on this earth,
which includes Supergirl,
when he was expecting
to find Clark Kent Superman, like,
wait a minute, you're not Clark Kent,
But it's all because of this concept
of hyper time with overlapping timelines.
The way that they describe
hyper time in the DC Comics is they
call it the vast, interconnected web
of overlapping timelines
that comprise all of reality.
Whereas when you think
of the traditional multiverse concept
like they did on the Flash TV show,
it's like you visualize the Flash running
through a bunch of different worlds
until he finds the one university's
looking for the reason why.
It's a little more helpful
to think of the way
that the Loki series talks
about different timelines
is that you
have this one Earth that the Flash is on
in present day with Ben Affleck's
Batman, the main Justice League Earth.
He uses the Speed Force
to travel into the past of that Earth,
but the Speed Force starts
to cause fractures in all the
different timelines that are overlapping,
which represent different universes,
essentially like the timeline
that is Michael Keaton, Batman's Earth,
where you get to the secret villain,
the dark flash that is an evil
Ezra miller from the future,
wearing this crazy looking suit.
It sounds like because the flash starts
to fracture all the different timelines
and they start to overlap and bleed
together.
He comes from a yet
another different timeline that just
overlaps and winds up
putting him on this earth with them.
And he's
meant to be a version of the Flash
that just never wound up
learning the lesson of Flashpoint.
Like sometimes you're not able
to use your powers to fix all problems.
Sometimes you have to learn to live
with people's death.
Sometimes you have to learn to take the L.
But for the most part, what you see
is what you get in the trailers,
like Michael Shannon Zod, Faye
or those Kryptonians are meant to be
the main villains for most of the movie.
I think the big twist with the Dark
Flash doesn't happen
until much, much later in the film.
So the using him a little bit more like
sabotage than they are the Reverse-Flash.
And they're not replacing reverse Flash
with this dark flash
that will probably happen
with Reverse-Flash.
And we probably see him in
like the second Flash movie.
If they wind up recasting the Flash,
We have no idea
if Ezra miller is going to stay on.
James
Gunn is kind of been both ways about it.
Like he could stay
or we could wind up recasting.
He could go either way.
I don't expect them to talk too much about
that until after the movie comes out.
They already removed some cameos
from Henry Cavill Superman
and I think Gal Gadot's Wonder Woman,
she might still be in some of the movie,
but they had some post-credits scenes
that set up a bunch of stuff to do.
Not going to pay off any more like future
crisis on Infinite Earths stuff,
which is part of an old plan
that they had before James Gunn was hired.
So I believe they're going to leave
the end of the movie
relatively open ended where it seems like
everything is different
and just full of potentiality,
like it could go anywhere.
Any of the future directors
that come on to do
these next couple of movies like Batman
The Brave and the Bold Superman Legacy,
which James Gunn is writing himself,
Anything that comes after
this could just point
to the end of the Flash movie
and say, Well,
everything was supposed to be different.
So because of what The Flash did,
it changing things.
At the very end of the film,
there was a new scene of Supergirl in her
Kryptonian suit on top of Michael Keaton,
Batman's Wayne Manor, getting ready
to take off and flight for the first time.
It seems like it happens after this scene,
too, just because of the costume change.
Like she's in her prison getup here inside
Wayne Manor, talking to the two berries,
and they're just
kind of nerding out on her, she explains.
Her name is Cora.
She gets her Kryptonian suit back,
and then it seems like she takes off in it
for the first time.
But she's flown before this
because you see her flying
when they break her out of that
underground prison.
The military had her in Batman.
It's like we just try not to die here.
I just seen a video
about all the different Batman suits,
all the different other Easter eggs
in the trailer footage.
I'll link those below in the comments.
And at the end of this, there's
a bunch of big stuff coming out though.
So if any of the questions
about other characters
that are in the movie or characters
that you don't see in the movie,
just write them below.
In the comments.
In related news,
they just announced that Jon
Bernthal is coming back
as the Punisher in Daredevil Born Again.
I'll do a video for that
after my Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode two Video.
That'll be the next video to post.
Everyone click here for that first footage
and teaser from Joker two to see
the three different versions of Joker
and click here for my Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 2 Video Update the link
As soon as I post that.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.